if we are really going to get in a
Stargate straight to cinema movie it's
got to be a Ronan Dex movie dammit
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so the rumors are
consistently now for nearly a year that
we're going to be getting a Stargate
straight to cinema movie now we have
discussed this on this channel many
times and we've basically said that is a
massive risk
the real problem is that if that movie
doesn't make its money back if it's a
massive flop and let's be honest with
the cinema recently we never know what
film is going to succeed and what isn't
it's just it's a crap shoot it really is
but if that movie does fail and just
flop it'll kill the franchise before it
even gets restarted and we desperately
want a franchise we want TV shows we
want prequels maybe and don't forget I
hate prequels and even I think that
would work in the Stargate franchise
universe and we want movies but we
really really want TV series that's what
we really really want
so how do you do a cinematic movie that
kick-starts the franchise as safely as
possible because we don't want to lose
money but also in a way that draws in
lots and lots of new fans because hey
they can do a Stargate movie and might
make us Stargate fans happy
but they need to draw in new fans if
we're going to Kickstart a new franchise
that can really succeed
so the way to do that bring back one of
the most popular characters in
stargate's history Ronin Dex and bring
back one of the biggest stars in
Hollywood right now Jason Momoa now I
actually know for a fact that Jason
Momoa loved working at Stargate Atlantis
he's still really good friends with
people like David Hewlett for example
and also Joe Flanagan these are people
that he would more than happily work
with again and actually has worked with
very recently because David Hewlett for
example did appear in C A series that
Jason Momoa did for apple plus
so there is a bit of a loyalty there
that if actually MGM and Amazon came to
Jason Momoa and said to fancy doing a
movie I actually think he'd go for it
the other thing is with Jason Momo he
actually likes really being involved in
the development work etc like that for a
big project that he's involved in he
likes you know getting involved in the
producer role and things like this if
you give him the opportunity with a
Stargate movie a Ron and Dex movie
I think you could talk him into it now
this would require a bit of a bigger
budget you'd have to probably pay him
about 15 million dollars to do it but if
you're really clever you could maybe be
pay him five up front and then give him
a percentage following the movie's
release this is something that's been
done a lot over the years and let's be
on it Robert Downey Jr did very well out
of it when he agreed to do Iron Man
so that is something that could be done
but what sort of movie would we want to
see well for one I'd like to introduce
you to health and safety guys cousin
trailer guy for a trailer that I would
love to see if this movie actually was
announced
[Music]
his home was destroyed his people
scattered
he made a new home on the ancient city
of Atlantis but when that was also taken
and he found himself alone once again he
knew there was only one thing to do
run and fight
Jason Momoa returns in his iconic
breakthrough role Roland Dex
in cinemas this fall
story line now for this film would be
quite easy Ronan Dex was a character
that's already been really fleshed out
and really the whole thing with him
versus The Wraith the whole Runner thing
would be very easy to build into a
storyline so maybe Ronan Dex has been on
the earth for a few years he's become a
little bit claustrophobic here we
already know he doesn't like small
spaces and he's decided maybe to go back
and try to fight The Wraith once again
maybe the Towery aren't being supportive
in that and he's left us finding himself
once again on his own battling The
Wraith maybe then along the way he does
make new allies maybe along the way he
does find out about a threat against the
Earth and have to then return to the
Towery and tell them what's going on
bringing them into the battle once again
I can actually see lots and lots of ways
how doing a rolandex movie allows us to
get over some of the problems about
actually Reviving this series because
it's not easy there are problems we've
got with Reviving Stargate series for
one
The Towering were very very powerful by
the end of sg1 and by the end of
Atlantis we were virtually walking with
the gods and at least another decade has
gone by so where are we now how
technologically advanced Are We Now what
are the threats that we're going to be
facing I've always argued that I want
Stargate not Star Trek and the whole
thing with Stargate was that it was
grounded in some sort of reality the
problem with where we were at the end of
sg1 and Atlantis is that we were so
Advanced that really we've lost touch
with all of that reality the Roman deck
storyline allows us to get back to
basics in lots and lots of ways by still
having the high concept and the high
value sci-fi but also a man running in
the woods with nothing more than his
sidearm to protect him so getting back
to basics I think is actually really
important for this movie casting it is
also vitally important to make sure that
we can excite non-gaters that they
actually want to go to the cinema to
watch this movie and that's why I think
getting Jason Momoa involved would be
incredibly important
but do I actually think this is even
remotely likely well according to the
sources that I speak to no that actually
Amazon's plan with the Stargate
franchise is to start sensibly but yes
they're going to have a straight Cinema
movie which is amazing and going to cost
a lot of money but their expectations
are sensible from what I've been told
that they know that this maybe is not
going to be the summer blockbuster
billion dollar movie but if it could get
a movie that maybe made two or three
hundred million dollars at the cinema
that would be a massive success for
Amazon and actually I think achievable
so it's probably not Amazon are going to
do
but in my opinion it's what they should
but guys you get into the comments tell
me what you think do we need a big name
like Jason Momoa to appear in this movie
if it's going to succeed or actually
there's one thing that the cinema has
shown Us in the last few years that
actually you don't need big names
anymore that actually you just need
something that excites people something
a bit different something that can
attract them to the cinema that's not
necessarily just a Tom Cruise or a Jason
Momoa name and they've actually lots of
projects with big names that have been
attached have failed miserably in recent
years
so maybe we don't need it but guys get
into the comments to tell me what you
think if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of our new
videos appear first and you get to see
them without the adverts for a small
contribution you can also go to our
dedicated website
sidetrack.co.uk where you can see stores
related to most of our new videos
as always guys please stay safe and I'll
see you next time foreign
[Music]